Candace Owens hosts the Candace Owens
podcast she joins us now I have to say
Candace Owens the one thing I will never
attack Joe Biden for is his age because
it's the one thing he doesn't control
and I have absolute sympathy for him I
hope to make it to that age so this is
not an attack on him for being old I'm
just amazed that no one around him
feels empowered enough to point out I'm
sorry you're too old to be president why
is that the one verboten thing why is it
the one thing no one can say
yeah you know I do feel some sympathy
for Joe Biden because obviously he is
mentally incapacitated but it does make
you want to question Jill Biden and
people like Gisele fetterman who
understand exactly what their husbands
are going through understand that
they're being mocked on the world stage
and understand that they are struggling
uh struggling even to form coherent
sentences and yet they sit there and
they applaud and they think we're just
going to keep hiding this from the
public all on their quest for power and
that's really what this comes down to
look we can call these people
incompetent they are but does
incompetency matter no because they're
here to serve the party this is all
Democrats care about you are here to
serve the party and actually if you are
incompetent that's even better right
because these are puppets these people
are on strings these people are to do
what they're told and not to think
expressly actually they are told not to
think individually think only about the
party do what we tell you to do and what
we want you to do is to further
disintegrate these communities is to
further denigrate these communities
because what we are after for as the
party initiative is full omnipotence and
what they need to create is a new system
of slavery this is why I call it the
ultimate thing that they are after is
Neo slavery they want to make sure that
no individual holds power in this
country and so what you're seeing is
something that's very evil you are
calling out something correctly and
saying that their final war is a war
against nature it's a war against sanity
it's it makes us question our sanity you
would never think that we would be
having these debates that we're having
today the people will be telling you
that it's a wrong thing to say that an
86 year old is old right so suddenly
we're being attacked for this everything
is given in ISM and the reason is just
as you correctly pointed out is because
it is the final war and they need to
make sure that they control even
language
well I think language is the key because
they've cowed the population even
smart people who know better into not
saying the obvious things their fears
that people will say the obvious things
you're too old to be president your
trans Admiral is a dude putting
incompetent people in the cockpits of
commercial airliners or having them
perform heart surgery is insane you're
insane like none of this is real you
can't allow this to happen
and those are the very things that no
one is willing to say I don't know why
I'm certainly not one of those people I
don't struggle to say exactly what needs
to be said and this is exactly why
because if they win if they win this
battle there is nothing left right there
is nothing left and so I encourage
people I say no you need to say the
thing that you know is true because the
problem that we're having right now is
too many conservatives are acting like
cowards right they're saying we need to
be nicer it's okay this is how they have
gained so much territory this is how we
are fighting them in the school systems
how we're fighting them in the
classrooms how we are fighting them to
Simply acknowledge that women can never
be men and men can never be winning
these are these are insane arguments but
they're able to happen because good
people sit by and say absolutely nothing
while they run amok and and so I also
want to say this and it's very important
to point out the Democrats used to be
quiet about their corruption right years
ago they were quiet about their
corruption now they're corrupt openly
and they're mocking you and what they're
really asking you is and what are you
going to do about it so what we knew
Federman was mentally incapacitated and
we still allowed him to make it all the
way to the Senate and what are you going
to do about it so what we know that Joe
Biden can't can barely walk we can see
the early signs of dementia and what are
you going to do about it it's a very
fair question I'd ask the same to
everybody out there watching this
program what are you going to do about
it why don't you start saying the truth
and Having the courage to say it boldly
can I say one last question as a wife
and mother which you are so here you
have Dr Jill and Gisele fetterman both
cheering on their husbands political
careers well one is effectively
incapacitated by dementia and the other
one's literally in a mental hospital
wouldn't you think that a woman who
loved a spouse who loved her husband
say no it's not good for him why is Dr
Jill not the villain in this story what
is her problem what a ghoulish
power-seeking creep and the same which
is Alfred her husband's in a mental
hospital like what
yeah absolutely these women are monsters
I'm not going to men's words here these
women are absolute monsters if you're in
a relationship and you love someone and
you've and you've had a family with this
individual you would never want to see
them suffer period now imagine wanting
to allowing them to suffer publicly
that's exactly what these women are
doing they are be they are somehow
become creatures on their quest for
power and they should be ashamed of
themselves but I promise you they won't
be because it's all about serving the
party and if they have to sacrifice
their husbands oh well
yeah if my wife did that to me because
you want to spend the weekend at Camp
David
my feelings would be hurt a lot
um Hannah so it's I appreciate it great
to see you tonight thank you
thanks for having me
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight